one two we know that we will never part
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh great work everybody
Troy I love that little Motown outro
thing super soulful cool thanks Lyle
yeah
just came to me so I went with it wow
it's crazy he's just uh we're the
acapella group mates oh hey Marty Lyla
what's going on buddy here get over here
guys this is my buddy Marc he just
transferred from Minnesota I thought he
could sit in on a few practices I don't
know maybe join the group
maybe all right guys let's do always
been my girl again from the top and my
girl Marc show us your stuff you got it
all right guys ready one two
[Music]
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh
[Music]
you gotta be kidding me
mark was out of this world okay well hey
just it just came to me so I just went
with it
great well keep going with it guys have
a safe weekend All Right see on Monday
nice to meet you guys man yeah that's
awesome isn't neither bathroom guys
great practice rolling good effort all
right yeah check you later guys see you
later alligators
thank you do I'm doing my very good
this is my seven white boys you need to
back Eddie I musta get mine tell if any
idea how long it took for me to
infiltrate you did I'm on roll over what
some folks at alas you know what white
boys is going do but white boys is gonna
do and if they want to run with a high
ass singing falsetto then that's on them
oh that's on man man oh that's all Neil
okay so it's like that always stole like
that well watch your back okay watch
your back was you
good what
[Music]
and improvised oh that's so cold out
it's gonna be dark soon
oh my god yeah we should build a fire oh
oh no it's a black cat hey man what a
cat got a beep black
man I guess I gotta put my dick away
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you